[Music]
on this Friday night struggling to
survive Sun Wings suspends flights it's
pretty surprising development with many
Canadians still stranded abroad a lot of
the people here starting to really
struggle mentally uh some physically
Trump's taxes what the documents reveal
about the former president's business
failures bad influence the Matrix has
attacked me why controversial Tick-Tock
star Andrew Tate is under arrest in
Romania and flashback to the Storm of
the Century how 2022 might be a sign of
things to come
global national with far NASA reporting
tonight Chris gayles good evening and
thanks for joining us amazing we're
still talking about it but the chaos
that emerged from last week's winter
storm is still very much a reality for
many Canadians stranded abroad tonight
while several Airlines experienced
disruptions in cancellations sun wing is
facing backlash from thousands of
customers as it continues to struggle to
bring people home the airline tells
Global News tonight it hopes to have
most if not all remaining passengers
home by Monday but calls are still
growing for Ottawa to take action with
so many people left in limbo nitu garcha
has our top story
to be in that situation feeling helpless
um is very uneasy feeling rod and
Rochelle Perkins finally returned home
to BC Thursday after a trip to Cuba
which they say took an unsettling turn
after handing over their visitor Visa at
the airport to fly home Wednesday the
flight was canceled without visas or a
flight home they say they were left to
the mercy of sun wing no one could we
cannot separate from the rest of the
passengers of the plane yeah so they put
us through a side door in the cube
airport we got all on a shuttle and they
took us to resort that we weren't even
familiar with a hotel that we weren't
even familiar with
and we couldn't leave that hotel over in
Mexico Nick dasovic says communication
from the same airline is still
inconsistent
there's about 500 people in the hotel
trying to get out the Canadian soccer
Hall of Famers one week family vacation
turned into nearly two weeks because of
canceled flights people are saying what
are you guys worried about you're not
you're in an all-inclusive down in
Mazatlan but you know a lot of the
people here are starting to really
struggle
Sunwing said it's navigating
unprecedented operational challenges and
that 40 recovery flights were planned
for this week but on Thursday the
airline announced it's suspending its
operations in Saskatoon and Regina until
after February 3rd it's pretty
surprising uh development you know five
weeks of canceled operations is pretty
dramatic in a statement Premier Scott
Moe called it a very irresponsible
decision by sun wing and that the
provincial Transportation Minister has
been in touch with the company and
Ottawa asking for a detailed plan of how
and when passengers from Saskatchewan
will get back adding they expect sun
wing to appropriately compensate
everyone the airline is offering refunds
to customers with flights already booked
but this passenger rights Advocate is
recommending they refuse those refunds
recommend passengers not to take a
refund but insist that sunwink provide
them with alternate Transportation or
pay for it we are not talking here about
situations like weather we're talking
here about business decisions economic
decisions and Sunway made a bad bad
gamble it's time to pay the bill I
really think your plan being plan C now
that's for sure when when we head out of
the country make sure the worst case
scenario is covered which just was as
passengers like Rochelle and Rod rethink
how they plan their future travel nitu
karcha Global News
hundreds of First Responders honored a
fallen Ontario officer today Constable
Greg Pierce challah died in the line of
duty protecting his community one of the
alleged Killers was out on bail at the
time and that sparking calls to reform
the system to Ria Israel reports
red and blue dotted Highway 400 as a
police procession escorted OPP Constable
Greg pershalla home
a black hearse carried his body from the
forensic Center in Toronto back to Barry
and his morning family you never know
when they leave home they may in fact
not even come home at the end of this
shift
First Responders and members of the
public lined overpasses to pay their
respects the rookie officer was gunned
down on his first official day alone on
patrol the fifth police officer in
Canada to be killed on the job since
September it's very distressing and we
all need to stand up
per Shala was responding to a call about
a stolen vehicle on a rural road a half
an hour from Hamilton that's when police
say he was ambushed pershalla was 28
years old Brandy Stewart Sperry and
Randall McKenzie are facing first degree
murder charges Mackenzie was out on bail
on charges of assaulting a police
officer and possessing a firearm we're
really continue we're in shock over this
and and you know
we're angry we're angry that this could
happen pershalla's death is renewing
demands for bail reform we just can't
have people over and over and over again
being released out into the streets
before the paperwork is even done the
Liberals changed the law three years ago
to modernize the bail system clear up
backlogs and stop the
over-representation of vulnerable
populations in Canadian jails we have to
find a very careful balance between the
rights of people who are safe to release
and them being released quickly and
those people who have a an established
history of being violent the Liberals
say they're looking at ways to improve
the bail system your conservatives are
following while opposition leader Pierre
pauliev insists the current policy is
failing I regularly meet police officers
across Canada who tell me that they
often have to rearrest the same person
in the same day per Shala will be laid
to rest Wednesday a death that shattered
the police community and reignited a
national debate tariya isri Global News
Ottawa
four people are dead including two
children after a fire in Hamilton
Ontario the fire broke out just after 11
o'clock last night with Crews arriving
to the townhouse unit fully engulfed and
reports of people trapped on the second
floor a total of six people were found
inside two are still in hospital in
stable condition an investigator with
the Ontario Office of the fire marshal
says it appears there were no working
fire alarms in the home the fire started
somewhere on the main floor
obviously the fire spread is pretty
significant through the entire ground
floor so your ground floor pretty much
your kitchen living room stairwell uh
main floor hallway like all that's been
pretty severely impacted
residents from neighboring units were
evacuated but have since been allowed
back home the cause of the fire is still
under investigation
to the United States now where Americans
are getting their first look at Donald
Trump's tax returns the release of six
years of documents shows the former
president lost millions of dollars and
in some years paid little if any tax
Jennifer Johnson now with more on what
the revelations could mean for Trump's
future
from private jets to living in massive
Mansions former president Donald Trump
is often claimed to be one of the
wealthiest Americans but now after years
of battling with Democratic lawmakers
Trump's tax returns have been released
painting a much different picture of the
so-called billionaire businessman here
is the most powerful man in the world
the self-described clever genius who
brags of his wealth almost daily and he
did not pay the taxes that the most
modest wage earner in this country would
pay the tax records show Trump claimed
massive business losses over 100 million
dollars in 2015 and he paid close to a
million dollars in taxes in 2018 but
while living the lifestyle of the Rich
and Famous Trump paid just 750 dollars
in taxes in 2016 and 2017 and no taxes
at all in 2020. the last year of his
presidency that apparently wasn't the
only time he didn't pay anything as
Hillary Clinton pointed out during the
2016 campaign and they showed he didn't
pay any federal income tax that makes me
smart Trump fought hard to stop his tax
returns from being released to the
public even taking his battle all the
way to the conservative controlled U.S
Supreme Court which ruled against him in
November other presidents have routinely
made their tax records public since the
1970s Americans should be greatly
outraged by that and by the failure of
the IRS under Trump to do its job to
audit him the way they have audited
other presidents the house Ways and
Means Committee released nearly 6 000
pages of documents from Trump and his
wife melania's tax returns and his
businesses Trump fired back in a
videotape statement although these tax
returns contain relatively little
information and not information that
almost anybody would understand their
extremely complex the radical Democrats
behavior is a shame other Republicans
are warning Democrats will pay for this
it seems to me that that obsession is
taking form today and will have severe
consequences Republicans take over the
house in January and are already vowing
multiple investigations into President
Joe Biden and his son Hunter but
Democrats say this is all about
accountability Jennifer Johnson Global
News Washington
the competition tribunal has cleared the
wave for the Rogers Shaw merger to go
ahead but it might not be a done deal
yet the tribunal dismissed an
application from Canada's competition
Watchdog seeking to block Rogers
Communications proposed 26 billion
dollar purchase of Shaw the tribunal
says the merger of the two
telecommunications companies would not
result in materially higher prices the
move still requires approval from
Innovation science and economic
development Canada and the competition
Bureau says it has filed an appeal
a controversial influencer arrested on
human trafficking charges coming up how
a public spat with environmentalist
Greta tunberg put the spotlight back on
his alleged crimes and they are gonna
need a bigger boat a West Coast fishing
trip pulls up a giant from the deep
controversial internet influencer Andrew
Tate will spend at least another 30 days
in a Romanian jail the former
professional kickboxer and noted
misogynist was arrested yesterday on
suspicion of human trafficking rape and
forming an organized crime group his
high-profile arrest follows a viral spat
he initiated with climate activist Greta
tunberg Redmond Shannon reports
hitch battles in which armies go to war
with machines of death and destruction
in mid-December before targeting Greta
tunberg on Twitter Andrew Tate posted a
trademark hyperbolic video to his
millions of followers promoting his
latest get rich quick scheme every
single thing that exists out there
inside Matrix is
The Matrix a reference to the movie
about a subjugated brainwashed
population
on Thursday night during his arrest he
mentioned it again the Matrix has
attacked me still on brand even as he
and his brother were detained in
connection with a human trafficking and
rape investigation Romanian prosecutors
claim an organized crime group was
sexually exploiting six people police
video of the raid on Tate's home showing
weapons cash and fast cars
the former kickboxer has long courted
controversy he was kicked off a British
reality TV show in 2016 after a video
emerged of him appearing to beat a woman
with a belt in Romania and I explain my
five reasons one of them is the metoo
era since then his misogynistic comments
have had him thrown off major social
media platforms he has said women are a
man's property and that rape victims
should bear responses ability for their
attacks they're called Morpheus all the
time in my DMs because I'm trying to
wake people up but he has still made a
fortune from that content Tate's fans
pay him to learn how to make ad Revenue
by reposting his most controversial
Clips which has led to his sharp rise in
prominence in the past year an
investigation from The Observer
newspaper said his subscribers were told
you want arguments you want war it's
worked out really well for the companies
too because they've made tons of money
by placing ads next to his must-see
content because it's must see not just
for those who like it but also for those
who dislike it despite AIDS misogyny the
sometimes Free Speech Champion Elon Musk
reinstated Tate on Twitter in November
while under arrest someone has continued
to post from Tate's Twitter account
Redmond Shannon Global News London
the consequences of climate change ahead
of devastating Storm's lasting scars on
Atlantic Canada
disbelief from those on board this
fishing vessel off the coast of
Vancouver Island as an unexpected
visitor clung onto their catch as it was
being reeled in
when we first started pulling the Trap
up it was super heavy so we just thought
it was a pretty full prawn trap and then
as it was like surfacing we're like oh
my gosh that is a huge octopus
the giant Pacific octopus was released
after putting on quite a show for the
fishing group however this brief
appearance will not be forgotten it's
already racked up more than 30 million
views online
well this fall Atlantic Canadians
watched in horror as hurricane Fiona
bashed their homes and businesses
causing one of the most expensive
climate disasters in the world this year
since the storm people are nervous about
the future and wondering what they can
do to protect themselves for the next
time Ross Lord reports
for Kevin Jewel windy days like this one
are unsettling they remind him of Fiona
the storm that destroyed his Dairy Barn
I'll have to admit I was I was scared
you just held your breath uh waiting for
it to subside and then it would come
again it was relentless and uh you know
and now when you hear wind I mean you
think you know I I think it's gonna
we're gonna have to think differently
thinking differently has become
unavoidable across Prince Edward Island
where some people went weeks without
power and in other Atlantic Canada
communities post-tropical storm Fiona
typifies the Dreadful reality of more
powerful storms attributed to global
climate change the insurance industry
says Fiona caused an estimated
660 million dollars in damage the most
costly storm on record in the region
that doesn't include additional
destruction that is not covered by
Insurance imported back Newfoundland and
Labrador Town officials say 81 houses
were destroyed or damaged Beyond repair
by Fiona's terrifying flying wall of
water one moment was swept out of her
house and died others are now afraid of
the ocean they'd always embraced
especially for residents maybe in the
highly impacted areas they're having a
fair bit of difficulty with when there's
forecast of bad weather people in Porter
Basque thought their Storm of the
Century was a 2021 rainstorm that washed
out sections of the trans-canada highway
stranding the town in both directions
less than a year later Fiona redefined
the term historic storm gouging of
chunks of land mass leaving more than 50
other homes vulnerable to Devastation
next time we have to look at what the
future of that looks like now as we go
forward in a rebuild in the days after
Fiona's devastating sweep through
Atlanta Canada the federal government
promised Disaster Assistance in the
hundreds of millions of dollars we need
to have a transparency and
accountability absolutely but we also
need to get the money to family as
quickly as possible especially with
winter coming especially with some of
the impacts to community infrastructure
and we're going to be there not everyone
is convinced we don't know what if
anything will be forthcoming from the
federal government Osborne Burke says
Fiona caused millions of dollars in
damage to the fish plant he manages in
Cape Breton as they rebuild with
additional reinforcements Burke says
insurance covers some but not all of the
cost the frustrating portion for us to
have to face with every day
is we're continuing to rebuild
uh
no understanding of what we're going to
receive if any the progressive
conservative Nova Scotia government has
released its own climate action plan
intended to limit the prospects of
future climate change Devastation the
plan promises big cuts in greenhouse gas
emissions with measures that include
restricting the use of oil heat to some
climate analysts the plan doesn't go far
enough what we didn't see in this plan
is a commitment to end outdated
Industries
uh we're we still have an open Coal Mine
in this province we have gold mines back
on Pei Fiona's impact lingers muscle
Growers who export more than 40 million
dollars worth of the shellfish annually
had hundreds of Acres of future product
washed out to sea
Kevin Jewell is still adjusting to the
loss of his Dairy burn it is a major
blow to our annual income he estimates
building a stronger barn on top of
what's left of the old one will cost
more than what his insurance company is
willing to cover we're scared for a long
time on the island as he navigates
government assistance programs jewel is
moving forward we could just get a roof
on here before we get too much snow
it'll be ideal working toward a better
New Year but more vulnerable than ever
to the unpredictable force of Mother
Nature Ross Lord Global News
[Music]
next what's most concerning to Canadians
heading into the new year
[Music]
as we near the end of it how was 2022
for you if you say pretty good you're
with the majority of Canadians who say
the year wasn't bad for themselves and
their families according to ipsa's
polling done exclusively for Global News
but there is still an overwhelming
number of people who feel some
trepidation heading into the new year
Global's Erica Vella looks at what's
causing such cautious optimism
compared to previous years how would you
compare 2022
I was fine after two years navigating
the covid-19 pandemic life has appeared
to return to normal but for many it
doesn't equal a shift in attitude I
think it was a time of some new things
getting back out there and being social
again but at the same time I know just
feeling a little flat we've come out of
a pandemic but we've haven't come out of
the pessimism ipso's polling shows when
looking back on 2022 about two-thirds of
respondents say the year was good for
themselves and their families when it
comes to the outlook for Canada people
are split but in a year that has seen
much turbulence with the war in Ukraine
people appear to have a more pessimistic
opinion on the state of the world you
name the the hot button issues also
throw in global inflation the global
economy it's a hot mess that's the best
way of describing it 2022 has also seen
a lot of economic uncertainty with
soaring inflation repeated interest rate
hikes and a looming recession it has
many wary of what's to come three
quarters of respondents agree that 2022
has made them fearful For an upcoming
recession and that's higher for
households with kids it's really a
concern to me as a single mom
it's not been easy so the recession is
really really crazy that talk has been
in the air a lot and so it's no surprise
that people are in a sense afraid of a
recession but experts are predicting a
recession that is much more mild
compared to those in the past growth
falters in the economy maybe the
unemployment rate goes up a percent or
two but not five or seven the way we've
seen in in these past recent recessions
polling shows many people also have job
security on their mind with 30 percent
of people agreeing that 2022 has them
worried about job security in the future
it's going to affect a lot of people and
I think probably the government's both
nationally and provincially need to do
better to provide for people who are
going to be affected taking it day by
day with hopes that 2023 brings on a
more confident sense of optimism the new
year is like today it's it's overcast a
little bit rainy but it's positive
numbers and hopefully that's the same
for the year to come positivity Eric
Bella Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Friday I'm Chris galus tonight's York
Canada is this beautiful snowy cabin
near Emerald Lake BC thanks very much
for watching Sonya Sunder will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow have a good night
and happy New Year
foreign